et pour en parler on va retrouver
olivier vernet secrétaire général du smn
à achat fo est médecin neurologue à
gonesse oui bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt trans alors on va
revenir sur les mesures annoncées un
pareil manuel macro et par christophe
castanet à ce qu'elle vous semble à la
hauteur de la pandémie
écoutez on verra moi je craignons à
l'hôpital déborde capacité d'accueil ont
vu de ce qui s'est déjà passé tally ont
tenu de ce que nous savons et
d'épidémiologique a fortement avoir
d'être dépassés capacité de
l'hydratation les deux lits
d'hospitalisation
tu as fait des programmes et des nombres
d'argent pour pouvoir accueillir ces
nouveaux malades il ya déjà plusieurs
cogite dans le vide par une unité
politique est plein on prévoit
d'augmenter l'activité de ces malades de
ces délits mais aux dépens des autres d
autres activités des tisanes moi cette
nuit qui a pas plu à des réalisations
parce que c'est déjà là mais j'ai des
collègues venant d'autres donc de match
le ballet match finalement on peut les
porter plus loin puisque et imprévus
plaint que olivier vernet emmanuel
macron a annoncé également le
déploiement d'un hôpital de campagne
militaire en alsace ajustements pour
venir en aide aux hôpitaux de la région
grand est est ce que selon vous cette
initiative doit être déployée partout en
france par tous et partout celui très
rapidement il y a une autre
interrogation qui qui est celle des
tests une pétition d'ailleurs circulent
pour que les professionnels de santé
soit obligatoirement
st est-ce que selon vous c'est
indispensable on en est ou sur ce sujet
là ces fameux tests et bien je fais près
clair normalement l'hôpital devait
tester tous les professionnels femmes
thomas grave et là je vais avoir une
interne qui après tout est et il a
maintenant simplement parce qu'il n'ya
pas c'est peut-être y a pas souhaité
être compris qu'on est malade
donc on ne peut-être que les cas graves
donc évidemment il ya par ailleurs une
application
alors certains disent olivier bardet
effectivement que pour lutter encore
plus efficacement contre cette pandémie
justement il faudra il faudrait axéens
sur ces tests aujourd'hui ce qu'on ne
fait plus en france quel est votre
regard sur cette question là je pense
que pour lutter contre la pandémie il
faudrait qu'on n'ait pas déjà détruit la
moitié dès l'été vitalisation depuis des
années mais là il faut redonner urgence
besoin de mal de tête de gel et de lits
d'hospitalisation et de l'hydrater pour
un tous les jours à venir
alors olivier vernet cette dernière
question pour les téléspectateurs qui
vous écoutent un conseil peut-être en
cette période de confinement que nous
vivons depuis deux heures maintenant et
bien lavez vous les mains rester chez
vous n'envoyez pas les parents
et s'il est malade il avait une très
content alors avant elle
merci beaucoup olivier vernet de nous
avoir répondu en direct sur ft frange
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général s h fo est également médecin
neurologue à gonesse